Trump is making things complicated once
again because there is a serious chance
that by the time people are casting
their votes in the primary uh he and by
the time the general election comes
around and he's campaigning against Joe
Biden that he's a convicted felon or
potentially close to becoming a
convicted felon and at least two
candidates now in the Republican field
Chris Christie and ASA Hutchinson are
expressing doubt about about whether
they could bring themselves to vote for
a convicted felon ASA Hutchinson told
Politico quote I'm not going to vote for
him if he's a convicted felon he also
went on to say I'm not going to vote for
him if he's convicted of Espionage and
I'm not going to vote for him if he's
convicted of other serious crimes and
I'm not going to support him they need
to put a little rationality to what is
said in that oath or that pledge
basically trying to negotiate with the
terms of the Pledge are in order for him
to be willing to sign on to it